depuis son arrivée à la maison blanche
il en a fait sa priorité la lutte contre
le coc vide 19 joe biden veulent a mené
tambour battant
il s'est d'ailleurs fixé un horizon cet
été je suis convaincu que d'ici l'été
nous serons sur la bonne voie pour nous
diriger vers l'immunité collective et
accroître l'accès aux personnes qui ne
font pas partie de la première vague de
vaccination en allant jusqu'aux enfants
je suis convaincu de la manière dont
nous allons mettre cela en place
mais ce que nous allons faire est bien
et je pense que nous pouvons y arriver
pour parvenir à cet objectif joe biden
veut mener une campagne de vaccination
intensive
après avoir dans un premier temps évoqué
le chiffre d'un million de personnes
vaccinées quotidiennement au cours des
100 prochains jours
il a lundi revu ses ambitions à la
hausse et annoncé un million et demi de
vaccinations quotidiennes dans cette
opération de grande envergure
joe biden a reçu le soutien des géants
de la grande distribution amazon et
wallmart qui ont proposé leur aide
logistique pour accélérer le processus
joe biden peut également compter sur
l'immunologue anthony fauci conseiller
qu'ovide de la maison blanche qui se dit
libéré de pouvoir tourner la page de
l'administration trump au sein de
laquelle il se considérait comme le
rabat joie de service il est très clair
que certaines choses qui ont été dites
que ce soit à propos de choses comme
identiques le rock inn et d'autre de ce
genre était vraiment gênante parce
qu'elles n'étaient pas fondés sur des
faits scientifiques
l'idée que vous puissiez venir ici et
parler de ce que vous savez des preuves
de la science laissez la science parler
c'est un peu un sentiment de libération
s'il est trop tôt pour pouvoir juger des
effets du décret anti qu'ovide signé par
le nouveau président dès son investiture
mercredi dernier les chiffres des
contaminations sont en recul depuis un
peu plus de quinze jours
un signe encourageant mais joe biden ne
veut pas faire dans la démagogie
'l'indice il a déclaré que les états
unis pourraient atteindre entre 600
milles et 660 1000 décès liés aux
coronavirus